hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of impaired I am one of your
delicious coach Chris cope and on my
left
JC cariah's I am little the world's
biggest pot heads and JC I am one of the
world's business partners no you drink
I'm sorry I'm an alcoholic and every
week we decide to bring our friends and
other social outcasts on the show we
have a bunch of games we drink we smoke
we have a great time you want to join us
it's a big mess but I think that
everyone here could have a good time
with it so please give your children out
of the room right now because if not
I'll go to jail
standing at 5 feet inches tall with a
live show record of 3000 kills
5,000 good decent shows and a bunch of
losses and three near major
career-ending booze you've seen him on
trutv's laugh tracks and his debut album
Sean Grant first of his name is
available everywhere hailing from Miami
Florida 305 Sean
killing from Atlanta Shousha
that's joj a ready to put the South in
your mouth
coming in at five six and weighing in
and how much you're supposed to weigh in
ninth grade you've seen her on Jimmy
Kimmel Live you see them on Comedy
Central or you might have seen them in
your mouth make some noise for the king
kneel down Chris is ready everybody
welcome to another episode of impaired I
want to give it up for our guests enjoy
your beverage put yours down your funk
that's good stuff now what we normally
like to do is we start off the show by
doing this we find out our secret word
let's find out the secret word for the
day or you know wait no sorry
if someone says the secret word of the
day you'll hear this that means whoever
said it means I got to take a drink and
if you say whoever says it more than
once just keep drinking and smoking
right Chris is gonna be leaving the
thing because I'm terrible right now but
yeah we made a sharp everybody's like
star shot hey know what happened oh this
is my mixed drink it's all good what the
[ __ ] happened eight times that was good
whoa that was really good whoo
sweet with a good sweet not a fan of
booze I like that okay good
um Jolly Rancher that way I didn't know
no I have no name for it I just got a
guest whenever I'm making shots it's all
just very much like what can I put into
a cup and hope for the best
pretty good pretty good
can we play our first game yeah you will
jump into our first game yes I'm so
excited this is the FIR this is actually
a second time we'll be doing this on the
show it's called what's in the box
JC now I'm gonna say this in there what
is in the box now that's a good question
what is in the Box you or anything like
that I'm gonna hurt me there's nothing
in here that's not my dad okay oh it's
just the one thing
Oh what is that I know what that is
don't say it don't say what it is ah oh
oh what is it alright you described a
little bitter okay
felt a little rubbery robbery it was a
piece it was like a rubber in a shape of
like an 8 or a it's like um like a like
a like you pull it with your hands like
okay you think it's like a finger trap
like a finger trap okay
oh yeah exercise
okay maybe maybe it's a flaccid dildo I
don't know stringy yes stupid yeah
like a stringbuilder like the model of
Chris's probably I'm just just like area
has to get the rap described but it it
is a conquering to be more precise as
the commander erection enhancers statue
comfort went unused for Paul I was
writing with his Chris cope sighs I felt
one before well I've used it before but
it had the thing attached a vibrated
right
that's all I didn't recognize brought
that he bought into that bar to the
house imagined I'd be me more cigar
cutter that's not on the camera it's a
god it looks like I thought it was a
cigar cutter cutter that's kind of why
Ghana cuz it had a different like a
misleading shape I wanted you to think
it was like that really it's for you
guys to touch something he's put around
what is that you that's you I bought
this today no you can get it using but I
gotta get accounts payable holes for
graphic for stretching because the
problem is and this is what I've read
when he's ready yeah yeah it also does
our research everybody does a research
thorough research um yeah if you don't
it gets real tight it's real hard to get
off especially oh you got Lube on your
hands I mean it gets very uncomfortable
very it's like opening a door now yeah
that's my favorite but straws everybody
they help me drink this episode's
brought to you by sativa the daytime
what's the weed or daytime sativa time
we've ever gotten it that's pretty
amazing is there more booze in that lose
your hat no no [ __ ] we're all out of
book we never we never hit it when
there's no booze it's always when
there's too much of it you know so many
cheese puffs in your bag I have one key
that's true that is a hundred percent
true I also can't someone help me with
hands not me yeah nice - man off-screen
thank you sir we got it guys thanks for
our amazing crew hey where'd you get
that soda right there christ almighty
I'm just being please excuse me Jeeves
you do have me some rum
yeah I got you a lot of this it's just a
lot of prep work I'm gonna bad that you
right by drinking the majority of the
now behind it
let's see what are we doing this long do
something dumb alright well you're
making that I'm gonna slap your truth
shut up set it up baby okay next game
we're gonna play guys it's to truce a
line there pretty much explain to stuff
you're gonna come on you're gonna give
us to truce and why and we're all gonna
figure out which is which oh then you'll
tell us the truth okay we'll start with
Sean first me first okay okay hmm
I've met Alonzo Mourning I was recruited
for a d1 college for basketball [ __ ]
or my father's been in jail for the last
30 years
I say yes to that year I'm a race
go Laura or your accurate who knows
right put you in a conundrum so yeah
even my father's been in jail for the
last 30 years my I've been I was
recruited for d1 basketball team or I
met Alonzo Mourning which which is oh
now I can I can I take a virgin I'll
talk about yeah go ahead tech okay one I
believe for a fact you've met Long's our
morning here from Miami Heat say you
have been going to games so I think
that's true - honest - [ __ ] honest
and see the blade has game so now we got
to know whether he's athletic - daddy's
in jail okay yeah
Shaun is athletic d1 no I took the g3i
Shaun is - well-adjusted as a man to
have had a father been in jail okay my
father already around and my father was
damaged and I sit the man before you
yeah you somebody know but yeah every
episode I don't think that it doesn't
make me feel she says the person who
sits with her and get surgery go I'm
gonna think it's the D I think that do
you want I think it was something Laura
like DGG really the Y is do you want no
what do you think no I agree
man I got more truck I got more trusted
you bud I got I got a say a man maybe
you can ball I'm not gonna [ __ ] on you
like that
well your daddy's and just so I'm gonna
say well yeah I was the d1 it's always
cool my pops is locked up in yeah good
morning that's okay there are trade I
was hoping that you could ball but it's
a job not be well I wasn't even I didn't
even make it past freshman team I wasn't
even that good so really it was a
bold-faced lie
yeah
strong you guys played ball in high
school football
oh yeah played football oh I played a
little bit of baseball and a played whoa
what was this catcher I know first base
[ __ ] yeah okay oh yeah Bobby Bonilla no
he was third base there Jeff Conine yeah
I was I was weird don't have to move as
much yeah what are yours what a mind
okay all right do you I don't get into
detail I just just say that the things
okay here we go up good um all right
little my three when I was in high
school I was in a screaming band if you
don't know yeah
screamo band I was a play lead guitar
and a screw you don't even know what
scream I love know how to confuse a
black dude scream yes scream always it's
emo but wood screaming don't worry emos
short for emotions and scream Oh is like
screaming your emotions okay it's a type
of music and don't worry about it it
doesn't exist any level of detail you
provided on this one actually feel like
true then then okay my second one
my cousin and I both hooked up with the
same girl within the same week yeah I'm
not gonna tell you who was first whose
level we can get into that or we're not
getting to dad he'll paint pictures down
to aiming this up well you know her name
so yeah yeah her name's information okay
and then the last one was I lost a bet
in high school and had to have five
birth control pills
because I lost this bet it was a NBA
Finals at 8:5 birth control pills yeah
it wasn't good it wasn't great Oh so
which one of those is alive do you think
Remo banned no Livi my cousin can be
like girl feel like the screamo band had
a ton of information okay but also but
hooking up with a girl had a ton of him
for me yeah that was specific
information right so I feel like the
skinny ones very mobile
right okay okay he knew a lot about it
though
okay yeah bong head thank you what you
got
screamo is absolutely the truth within a
week of each other that's not that's not
true cuz I mean you shot against me and
his cousin Wow I understand nothing
might be really handsome that's what
happened she was [ __ ] which one
the final one the five birth control
pills okay all right I got your vote
vote was the four screamo bands a lie
okay [ __ ] bands a lie I think I'm also
gonna say you want to scream abandon
it's Govan all right
screwby is true we still we still have a
myspace check out my face hey shut up
silence before sunrise the page says
r.i.p it's real sad but go to the song
they're still up we wanted to keep the
songs alive so check out the my space my
space I hope back slash slash before
sunrise I'm in the top eight you came to
see my personal page it's real if
they're all out there no you were right
the birth control pill is [ __ ] me my
cousin yeah done that like we live sure
like you know you've all kind of some of
those one girl it was an accident it
wasn't on house an accent you fall into
her yes what's the next game jasmiyah
freak
it's where exact times I've done a game
what a jump into Oh interesting stories
in intoxication okay I'll go first just
mine's a little short and yours a little
bit long shore cool mine happened wait
hold on you forgot
brought to you by our sponsors we don't
know
not yet [ __ ] fingers crossed I can cross
to my fingers
straws my my interesting story that I
want to give you guys is David Wells
okay
may 17th 1998 David Wells pitched a
perfect game not a no-hitter a perfect
game means you were tired 27 batters in
a row didn't give up a hit didn't give
up a walk and he did it half drunk oh he
had been out drinking the night before
didn't get to bed till 5:30 yeah had to
be up at 6:30 now all of us have had
those nights oh hell yeah gotta get to
an airport got to do something but you
don't got to go out and pitch a
major-league game I have had to I've
literally I've drank till 3:00 in the
morning and woke up the next day and
went I don't know if I can do the show
tomorrow today they pick you up at 6:00
p.m.
yeah and you were completely just like
hey man he's turned the OSI on and I'll
drink a gallon of water he'll be fine
does he joke the perfect show every time
yeah that's up there turns on in the
heads okay how about this David boys
look like me and went out and pitched a
perfect game 15 people have done this in
the history of Major League Baseball
right [ __ ] 1562 games a year I think
I'm a name that's weird I mean it's it's
astounding and a guy who looks like a
dude who would fix your [ __ ] car
right who showed up still drunk is if he
would have been a 5 a.m. you're still
shit-faced you're waking up shit-faced
that my question were sent my questions
what team was he playing
twins [ __ ] retiring go that [ __ ] face
walrus just struck all of us out
Bouguereau
have to tell that story no he told that
every time we were right yo I was drunk
what I did that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I did it blindfolded you know he you
think about this he smelled like a
[ __ ] open bar because you know by the
third inning every single pour in his
body is leaking goddamn booze it's a
[ __ ] baseball no but I know the point
that I'm making is he didn't have to
tell his teammates anybody that was in
fire I am reporter within five feet of
him would've goes oh you smell like a
[ __ ] TGI Fridays like you know like I
mean it's I just I think baseball's were
the hardest things to do and the fact
that he did more the way he pitched the
whole game means you have to pitch the
home you know everyone no hits he could
have been out there by himself down so
he could have literally been like hey
the rest of the Yankees was the bearded
salmon I got this because that's all he
was drinking top-shelf for him and here
it's El Matador tequila yeah and I'm
about to pitch a perfect game sit out
outfield well literally the guys said
hold my beer watching a taquito watching
meet this cheeto wanted to [ __ ] talk
like a [ __ ] businessman you want to
do your all your great to your grand
moment all right I think it's I think
honestly it's another baseball based one
but it's not about baseball at all
really it's all the only thing is is
that the person involved in it was a
baseball player it's a record that will
stand the test of time in my opinion and
that is as a person who can drink a [ __ ]
ton of beers like I can sit up I could
drink a lot of beers in one sitting and
Wade Boggs
oh hi another box tour it's always sunny
oh yeah episode I don't know if he was
playing with Atlanta when he did it but
on a cross-country flight so going East
Coast to west coast or west coast East
Coast
he drank in one sitting sixty four beers
sixty-four beers that's on a plane how
old are sixty four beers on a plane
there's a live there's a lot of beers on
the plane it's five hours that's like 12
now we're good 12 an hour
well that's whatever whatever five he's
gotta have so that's what every five
more of the five hours he's getting 13 I
got it for the five hours he's hitting
13 beers
that's absurd I don't want five minutes
45 minutes working the hard man I mean
the five minutes 64 I can't imagine
dreaming because I felt like I think I
would enjoy rest friends because I've
showed up someplace with an 18 pack and
I've seen you crush it and drank an 18
pack of beer and everyone was like that
guy's a monster he's gonna die
and what did they say to Wade Boggs in
that moment I wanna know how come nobody
said no after he's weighs rocking but
one way he's weighed [ __ ] Boggs sir
you've had 60 please stop
how was he talking how is he speaking
words how did he order the 64th beer he
played baseball to jack piston you
started pissing in half not like get
weighed one more we got a record dissent
and just urinating in his first-class
seat like get away one more I don't know
there's had to be an off day right if he
didn't gotta be I think that's before
that's proof positive
I agree
bribing flight he drank 64b many went 3
for 7 - double - he made a leg amount
they would have been tripled against a
twin twins oh my god now I think it's a
remarkable thing
it's crazy but you never hear that
LeBron James but yeah that baseball I
our baby ate hot dogs and [ __ ] and then
would just go play baseball the NBA NBA
players [ __ ] base to smoke in the dugout
open to like the late 80s but I mean
dude dude likes [ __ ] smoke step off
and have a cigarette
I'm playing professional athletics yeah
what's up next America American [ __ ]
table America all the way through I
really have to ask this happens how many
beers how many beers have you honestly
drank in one sitting I just need to know
zero for me you know you don't drink
beers but how many bit like I mean
nobody hears bigger on account I don't
know a night wearing up keg standing
pretty hard right and like beer pong
game right and you know it was not you
know when you're in college anyway then
you'd go like what did you have maybe 15
maybe - well yeah oh my god but like you
know nice we're like you wake up and
your body's like if Tron take since yeah
do I haven't had a night work I woke up
I was a college party
college party and so I wake up from this
college party and I'm like all right I
got dicks all over my face load my body
whatever and then I feel like okay
whatever leave your body right yeah and
then I was
yo I can't really move my feet well I
cannot move this is weird as [ __ ] I
looked down they superglued my feet and
my toes that's good
why is this a black people don't do this
and for all y'all [ __ ]
superglue my [ __ ] then I'm like all
right dude I got it off and [ __ ] and I
was like yo I got my foot on glue it is
a white guy thing yo my roommate moved
my car once while I was asleep
I'll [ __ ] turn nation into a hostage
he's exact opposite rob wake him up at
9:00 a.m. to move the car he wants to
punch me no he'd let a child lose his
car he doesn't he get her bad hand
because everybody yo yo I got worse
sauce so I was like Weston
yeah and worse than my feet together I
woke up and I was like where am I
[ __ ] know I was like where my car
keys I was like I need to know our keys
like where Oh as I go you know check the
freezer
they froze veins are bad I think the
moral the fiery nice if I knew why why
guys white guys there's any we have to
get over it we're gonna do a segment we
like to call wasting where we make the
most tasty fantastic horrible high-end
drug foods let's jump into that right
now
[Music]
and as you can see we've made a
fantastic little food item they are pop
charts and good God do they look
delicious
PB PB&J with strawberries we go
strawberry yeah strawberry pop-tart with
grape jelly and peanut butter in the
middle grape jelly
Oh Berry is backing it decadent guys
we're gonna need napkins on this one
oh this is really good man hmm we did
one recently there was a JC donor side
of that bowl the protein oh yeah yeah no
napkins Road napkins got it
thought he was trying to tell me to be
better at showing things know when I'm
gonna desert wise solid if you're high
as [ __ ] or drunkest [ __ ] and you have
peanut butter and jelly and to pop
charts you could make something they can
change your [ __ ] life starting your
day with this [ __ ] that what soldiers do
not like bad day whatever it's midnight
in your life
Church and you people to jelly [ __ ]
toaster Bob yeah make it yeah that's
[ __ ] good George the tournament I
really don't I really don't endorse a
[ __ ] ton of these [ __ ] winner no [ __ ]
this wins
[ __ ] the twins but we bought these what
we call him Chris what's the name o PP
in jail
tarts very creative on it slapped our
peanut butter joke if these go viral
something's wrong with the world
those are [ __ ] amazing they're really
good yeah trying on this is legit let
real quick let the pop rocks cool for a
second before you put the peanut butter
he's such a chef about it Chris
experience no way there's no way you can
not like that was all I was a saying
that I got the method for it don't burn
the [ __ ] pop-tart yes real so I knew
win if you don't burn the pop-tarts to
win keep it on three you gotta be on
three right the pop-tart you hear that
drink Paul introduced in the Cabiria
yeah sometimes be response I'm you
kicking shower gun guys wasty check it
out that's beautiful
chair jump into our final game of the
evening oh I know I'll go it's not no
don't worry don't worry you know to go
home you just can't stay here over I
know still man yeah preach owner do
people tell you how to Oberer everybody
here gets home safe and gets in safe
thank nobody goes home [ __ ] up uber
live gets in their car
thank you I got her so after this
goddamn bomb you know you have pop-tart
in your drink coming into our final game
it's called beer on bartender we're
gonna get a cocktail a clue and then
we're gonna make a
afield in 97 all right guys we're
dropping into our game be your own
bartender we're gonna find out what our
cocktail is and we're gonna get a clue
that's by now
today's cocktail is a dark and stormy
and legend has it that this drink was
invented more than a hundred years ago
by members of Bermudas Royal Navy
officers clubs they described its
ominous hue as the color of a cloud only
a fool or a dead man would sail under
starting right this is dark for sure
damn right black there already is a
ginger beer opens right there a little
bit
hey spills okay fellas chillin dog
spilling is chilling one name juice what
feeling dirt
we got time spilling any so we got more
wait where we had time went roasted a
minute Chris always make some sweetest
[ __ ] I know
thirty Seconds go wrong that's a lot of
time yeah
all right you're shaking it up already
yeah good meals done he's just drinking
seven in silver always let's pour it in
yeah 15 seconds
oh [ __ ] I did not get the desired color
effect I was going for yeah I know
cloudy washing Wow look I'm Tom Cruise
over here yeah Christopher koppenhaver
explaining your drink and then pads
along here pass it to me okay hold it up
and then we'll talk about it so it is
just some through its three simple
things
Tanqueray a little bit of ginger beer
and a little bit of grenadine I was
hoping it would be darker like the red I
just don't know we're working with gin
gin ginger beer and grenadine so the gin
in Jin Tian Zhu hey
it's tasty it's tasty
let me try you don't like like a flower
oh [ __ ]
I don't eat flour I even challenge it I
really you know what I was all right it
was all right it wasn't good don't lie
to rum and ginger beer very simple very
Romney and ginger beer what kind of rum
you know that Bacardi white cardi white
and ginger man that Bacardi Caucasian
[Music]
what's your thing
tasty spud crisp crisp to the point
Chris you know there's good light grill
light to the point it's to the point the
light drink you wash it yeah you know
what it is
ain't that dog and stormy you know said
Dargis stormy Daniels it's a very like
it's a very light light light light that
is north we'll call that a stormy
Daniels that's pretty clever
thank you thank you pay you dog that's a
pretty good drink is the right read
y'all make it my main man Sean well mine
is I consider the the story
epoxides me drink and it had everything
to do with darkness as you would in a
cloud that you wouldn't want to navigate
under so that's why I chose here the
black girl brown their black rum and
Bushmills
oh no red bush with oh no double blue
I'm not sure the Bermuda army had Diet
Coke but didn't put you with daikon I
went to dyes coke and ginger beer so now
we're rum whiskey Diet Coke and ginger
beer and ginger beer a little taste
fixers jackers let's see what do you
think Cheers
sailors is delicious did you find it -
you about to [ __ ] me up back I want to
[ __ ] on it so bad because they should
not mix but it's not terrible it's not
terrible it's bad but it's not terrible
okay
take a sip of it okay you're gonna hate
it and alcohol would go away if I have
to okay you got it
no no Neil take it brother
I know I get none of them so honestly a
bit I felt like I knew what a dark and
stormy
I'm sure yeah right I felt like I knew
what the ingredients were which is dark
rum and ginger beer so that's what I did
it's just dark rum no Bushmills and
ginger beer
pretty sure it's pretty on point but it
also honestly has a very similar flavor
to Sean's yeah it's more clever what
flavor-wise I would not vote for it but
I just I think it's just because I don't
like dark and Stormies let's find out
what what was in it what's in the
darkest army a dark and stormy is bade
by combining two parts dark rum and
three parts ginger beer and fresh lines
[Applause]
really good mom was good no no no
because you went you went white wrong
you would clear Ronald Lewis sailing
that's what and that's why in this
moment I will say I was closest to the
beverage but because that's not my
favorite beverage Neel Nanda with a
brand new beverage what I think everyone
should drink the story
[Applause]
only cost $130,000 I want to say this
thank you guys so much for coming
everybody
I chose tell us what tell us where we
can find you guys that know at neelanand
on all social medias and follow me in
the streets Shawn grant pictures on
Instagram and act Shawn grant words on
Twitter I think you gonna you can find
us on impaired show yeah I have a parent
show on Twitter and Instagram
hey thanks guys thank you so much love
you you know what it is yeah girl
[Music]